charlize it is so nice to see you again
um out of the entire cast which two
people would you love to go on a road
trip with
oh for sure snoop dogg that's a
no-brainer
i would my girl chloe moritz was i think
i think that would be a cool road trip
that was that sounds amazing
what would be your number one road trip
song
something by snoop dogg
i love this
okay shout out to snoop shout out to
snoop um as a mom is it fun doing
kid-friendly roles do they get to enjoy
it
oh god yes because i mean
who we kidding my movies will not be
seen by them until they're like 52. so
i
you know and i think all the parents if
they're not saying this they're lying we
want we want to impress our kids and
it's really hard to impress your kids
kids are like the least impressed by you
it's such a good check-in to your ego so
there's like they're still cool about it
but i think deep down inside i can see
they they're really happy that i'm part
of these films oh
what would you say is your favorite
morticia trait
i think her dry sense of humor
yes very dry i love that about her
yeah
chloe said adam's family three are you
down for another oh my god yes yeah at
any time i have absolutely loved
exploring this world and this character
and my kids love them and
um
yeah if there was a need for another one
for sure
yeah
when will you be filming the old guard
too because the movie was amazing
obviously we want more
yeah we're in the pre-production stages
right now so i i we will
probably start shooting next year
we don't know exactly when so there's a
lot of kind of moving parts in it right
now but we're zeroing in on locations
and and we have a really good script and
so it's all looking very very promising
and yeah when he joined us as a director
and we're very excited about that
awesome what would you say is your
favorite part about doing voice over
work
the favorite would definitely have to be
the fact that you don't have to go
through hair and makeup and you could
pajamas that's definitely that's a
winner in my book um
yeah i mean that's pretty good but i
think i mean i think also
when you're making these movies you're
always kind of
keeping your audience in mind you know
and that's nice like i think for me
that's very personal i think of my girls
i think of the things
that they find funny and yeah and that's
fun
yeah
what is something that's coming up that
you are excited about that you're able
to share
well halloween is coming up and my kids
love halloween and so
there's a lot of planning going on in
our house right now and things are very
back ordered so
we are
home designing some things it's a it's a
big project in our house right now that
is very exciting and i will probably
post
something about that so that is
something to look forward to people
because i always end up in an outfit
that doesn't fit me
awesome thank you for your time pleasure
thank you so nice to talk to you nice to
talk to you
you